[Ukraїner
Країна ззовні]
Одна з найголовніших місій полягала в тому,
щоб зберегти вільну українську науку.
[Мюнхен,
Німеччина]
Сам університет, Український вільний
університет, неспроста так називається.
Якщо ви називаєте
університет українським,
то це не тільки декларація того,
що він належить українцям,
але й декларація того, що це університет,
в якому викладають українською мовою.
Якщо ви берете «вільний»
— то чому ж він вільний?
Дуже просте пояснення.
Вільний — через те, що наука, якою
займаються в цьому університеті,
не піддається політичним впливам.
Ніякий політичний чинник не впливає на
розвиток науки у стінах цього університету.
І якщо ви комбінуєте університет
(це ж не є якийсь науково-дослідний інститут, це є університет),
значить, ми займаємося не тільки наукою,
а ми також і викладаємо, готуємо молодь.
І з огляду на те, що університет
був заснований на еміграції,
то друге завдання полягало в тому,
аби не загубити,
не втратити свою ідентичність,
не загубитися в цьому міжнародному морі
і пам'ятати, хто звідки,
так би мовити, вийшов,
і пам'ятати, хто до чого приналежний.
Ми прямуємо зараз до будівлі
Українського вільного університету.
[Роман Яремко
викладач УВУ]
Фактично цей будинок, який належить
зараз Українському університетові,
і це є будинок, в якому
навчаються наші студенти.
Ось цей будинок.
Ви бачите, що він знаходиться фактично
в такому житловому районі.
Тут дуже спокійно, затишно.
Коли ви заходите всередину, у приміщення,
то там взагалі суцільний спокій.
Усе це є дуже важливим, бо наука,
навчання вимагають деякою мірою спокою,
тому, я думаю, що ця локація,
саме розміщення університету
є, звичайно, дуже вдале.
Ось це головний вхід.
Емблема університету.
Заснований був цей університет
у 1920-му році у Відні.
І так склалося, що ця установа
у Відні не прижилася.
Університет разом зі своїми викладачами
і також студентами змушений був переїхати до Праги.
З 1921-го року УВУ до кінця війни,
до 1945-го року перебував у Празі.
Ви повинні собі уявити ситуацію
1945-го року і Прагу.
Цей університет,
Український вільний університет,
в принципі, стояв завжди
на заваді радянській владі
і він, зокрема, стояв також
на заваді особисто Сталіну.
Наскільки мені відомо
з історичних джерел,
Сталін особисто також
цікавився тим університетом,
тобто було одне засідання,
де він запитував:
«Я чув, що в Празі існує
український університет».
Тобто, цікавилися не тільки університетом,
цікавилися, очевидно, також людьми,
які цей університет утримували,
які в ньому працювали.
І от ситуація,
де радянська армія наближається,
і тоді зібрався сенат УВУ і почали
думати, що ж ми маємо робити.
У нас є великі архіви,
у нас є велика книгозбірня,
і, зрештою, у нас є також люди.
Їх треба рятувати, треба рятувати,
очевидно, нашу бібліотеку. Як бути?
І думки, взагалі-то, розходилися.
Тобто, серед людей, які вирішували
фактично, як бути далі з університетом,
знаходився, наприклад,
тодішній ректор — професор Яковлів.
Він був за те, щоб з університетом
переноситися далі на Захід,
переходити, так би мовити,
у Західну Німеччину.
І був у той час також в УВУ
в Празі Августин Волошин.
Якщо ви пригадуєте
таку історичну постать —
він був президентом
Карпатської України в 1939 році.
От він вважав, що треба, все ж таки,
лишатися і спробувати рятувати,
і може з нами нічого не станеться і тому подібне.
Яковлів це відкинув і все ж таки взяв тих людей,
які хотіли їхати далі на Захід, забрав з собою і виїхав.
Ректорські повноваження в УВУ у Празі
в той час перейняв на себе Августин Волошин.
Наскільки утопічною була ідея лишитися
у Празі, показали найближчі дні.
Усіх, хто залишився, заарештували.
Волошина також заарештували,
вивезли, очевидно, в Україну,
і він у тюрмі там загинув.
Більшість тих людей, які лишилися,
також або пропали безвісти, або загинули.
Тобто, ось такий початок.
А ті, хто виїхали у 1945-му році,
знайшли осідок в Мюнхені
і почали, так би мовити,
з нуля відбудовувати все те,
що було втрачено у Празі.
І наш новий формат захисту
буде як проходити?
Але ми, студенти, достатньо гнучкі,
у нас є здібності адаптуватись
до будь-яких умов,
тому захистимо і в Zoom'і.
— У тебе пари були в Zoom'і?
— Були, були!
А в мене не було! Тому я й хвилююся.
Тому що я не знаю, як це.
За цими залізними дверима...
Сподіваюся, десь тут є світло.
Ось воно тут сховане.
Оце є, фактично, один з найбільших
скарбів цього університету.
Це є його архіви.
І от подивіться, ми зараз є в кімнаті,
де фактично зібрана уся періодика.
Це є найбільше зібрання української
еміграційної преси в Західній Європі.
Ви тут можете знайти буквально все.
І в цих газетах частково теж є історія
української еміграції в Західній Європі,
бо все, що створювалося, очевидно,
фіксувалося в тих часописах,
щоб якомога більше людей ознайомилося
з досягненнями українців за межами України.
Так...
[Надія Хоманчук
Наукова працівниця бібліотеки УВУ]
Архів УВУ насправді дуже великий,
приблизно у нас є мільйон аркушів,
тобто безліч різних справ.
Це архіви організацій, приватні архіви,
архіви, присвячені певній тематиці,
скажімо, чи Голодомору, чи ОУН
чи взагалі українській діаспорі.
Це, відповідно, є архів самого УВУ,
це є архів також
Антикомуністичного комітету.
Але зараз я вам хотіла
показати одну теж дуже цікаву річ,
яка належить до довоєнного часу.
Це дуже маленький архів
Клюбу «Україна» в Гамбурзі.
Що це є?
Тобто, українська діаспора
існувала в Німеччині,
відповідно, також
і до Другої світової війни,
просто не така численна, як раніше.
І ця діаспора, ці українці, які
компактно проживали в Гамбурзі,
створили таку своєрідну організацію,
клюб, як вони називали, —
Клюб «Україна», який був покликаний
допомагати українцям з різних питань.
Тобто, як з фінансових — позики
якісь надавати, з юридичних,
так і просто якась моральна підтримка чи
консультація щодо життя в Німеччині і т.п.
Ці документи, які в нас є, належать
до кінця 20-х — початку 30-х років.
Є один документ,
який я вам дуже хотіла показати.
Це список продуктів,
які члени Клубу «Україна»
(вони теж платили членські внески)
хотіли надіслати для українців,
що голодують в Україні.
Тобто це є 1933 рік.
Товари, які вони надсилають для Комітету.
Ось тут є навіть штемпель
німецькою та українською.
У Німеччині тоді існував Комітет
допомоги голодуючим в Україні.
І це є лист, список стандартного пакета,
який буде передано в Україну через
Комітет допомоги голодуючим в Україні
10 жовтня 1933 року.
Дуже приємно з вами так зустрітись.
Я пам'ятаю, моє перше заняття в УВУ
якраз відбулось теж у такому форматі.
Я прийшов на заняття,
вийшов викладач з філіжанкою кави,
зібрав нас всіх у півколо
і каже: «Зараз будемо займатися».
А хто це був?
— Масюк.
— А, пан Масюк!
Я до таких форматів ще не звик
на той момент, але це було дуже приємно.
Це є український університет,
який знаходиться за межами України.
Тобто, його вже тепер не можна назвати
еміграційним університетом,
бо з того моменту,
коли Україна стала незалежною,
українська еміграція в Німеччині
чи в інших країнах світу
перетворилася на діаспору.
Але унікальність полягає в тому,
що Україна має за
своїми межами інституцію,
яка у статусі університету
проводить діяльність
в інтересах української
культури, науки і так далі.
Це є великий чинник.
[німецькою] Україна.
Тобто, тут не так вона карта,
як більш, власне, графік такий.
Вона була видана у Відні у 1920 році.
Тобто, можемо сказати,
що ця карта більше покликана
подати інформацію про Україну
для німецькомовних осіб.
Скажімо, [німецькою] «Україна», ось тут є коротко історія.
«Хто не бажає собі самостійної
суверенної української держави?
У першу чергу, москалі.
У другу чергу, поляки».
[сміється]
І тут вони пояснюють, чому і хто має що проти,
щоб Україна була незалежною.
І теж звернемо увагу,
як зазначені кордони України тут,
тобто Донщина і північна частина Криму
— теж етнічні українці.
Ви знаєте, що в університеті в нас
є багатий архів та бібліотека.
І дуже багато матеріалів
я зміг собі почерпнути до своєї теми,
а саме «Українська військова еміграція
у 20-30-ті роки ХХ століття».
Тобто, як після
національно-визвольних змагань у 1921 році
українські військові,
які залишились без армії держави,
виїхали на Захід у пошуках нової долі.
І особливо в напрямах воєнної
психології та воєнного побуту,
як переналаштувалися
військові в нових умовах,
я вважаю, це досить актуально на сьогодні —
не просто досліджувати воєнні операції
та історію як фактаж та сухі дані.
І ми маємо можливість,
маємо цей унікальний архів,
де зберігаються
і світлини, і карти, і енциклопедії,
з яких у Радянському Союзі
були просто вирізані сторінки,
а ми маємо дійсно оригінали цих документів.
І якраз через те, що університет
знаходився за межами України,
вдалося багато що зберегти.
І це, дійсно, просто неоціненний матеріал для всіх робіт.
Тому я можу уявити.
Я все дуже хочу добратися до цього плівкового архіву, який є в УВУ.
В УВУ який?
[сміються]
В УВУ є аудіоплівковий архів і треба
буде купити спеціальний пристрій
і розшифрувати, оцифрувати ось це все.
Ми зараз є в такому світі,
де глобалізація є не тільки
в економічному плані, а й в культурному плані.
І те, що відбувається обмін між людьми, він тепер відкритий і доступний.
Воно, очевидно, збагачує
не лише українську,
але й також, скажімо, німецьку,
можливо також і англійську,
й інші культури і літератури.
УВУ і, в принципі, я думаю,
кожен викладач, який викладає в УВУ,
розумів свою діяльність у плані моста.
Завжди була мова про якусь сполучну
ланку між Україною і Європою,
тобто відбувається якийсь трансфер знань,
культурних, наукових здобутків.
Воно, можливо, на перший погляд, непомітне,
але якщо заглибитися в деталі,
якщо справді тим займатися,
то можна помітити, наскільки
оці процеси впливають на нас.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Інтерв'юерка
Ольга Войтович]
[Режисери
Микола Носок, Василь Гошовський]
[Режисер монтажу
Дмитро Бартош]
[Оператори
Анна Савчук, Павло Пашко,
Сергій Коровайний]
[Продюсерки
Каріна Пілюгіна, Катерина Акварельна,
Наталія Панченко]
[Асистентки продюсерки
Ксенія Фукс, Євгенія Лисак]
[Субтитрувальниця
Діна Безсмертна]
[Коректорка
Леся Любченко]
[Ukraїner]